do you ever meet Clapton yeah I mean
that's an interesting story because I
was watching the Queen's Jubilee when I
was 11 and he came on and played the
first
um
and I was like oh what the hell is that
and then my dad's like oh that's that's
that's Layla and I uh got the Derek and
the Domino's album I got the the Eric
Clapton Greatest Hits I bought uh Eric
Clapton unplugs and just learned all
these songs that performance was this
yeah
amazing Phil Collins on the ground
another bus Story how it is I bought the
sort of replica guitar of the guitar
that he was playing at the Queen's
Jubilee and there's this guy that does
this amazing music program in England
called Jules Holland and I played a
Jules Holland show with that Eric
Clapton guitar and I remember waking up
New Year's Day because it aired New
Year's Eve and I got this email and it
just the title was just e and uh it just
said nice guitar and I was like I think
think that's Eric Clapton and uh yeah we
just got friends from there Sean Clapton
was one of your Inspirations to even go
into music in other words you're 11
years old and then you pick up the
guitar and you start to work out Layla
on your guitar yeah it was the first and
only thing that I could play for a long
time and also the my first you still
play it can you still play it I'm not
like the world's best guitar player
[Music]
well you do it you get lonely
no one Waiting by your side
you've been around hiding much too long
you know it's just your Foolish Pride
later
got me on my knees lb guitar I'm viewed
as like not a great guitarist that we
could tell people around the world being
like what's he doing murdering this song
Do you ever shred do you do you that's
like that's right that's the one thing
that I can't really I sort of made a
choice when I was younger I was like if
I want to be Eric Clapton or John Mayer
I learn all this and if I want to
be Damien Rice I learn four chords
foreign